- [Narrator] Nothing
in Portugal stands out
quite like the vibrant colors
and unusual architecture of Pena Place.
Pena National Palace is located
within western Portugal Sintra Mountains.
Although the palace's very design touches
make it appear as though it has been built
from multiple pieces of different castles,
the building's unusual style
is the result of an owner
with extremely flamboyant tastes.
The palace was owned by King Ferdinand II,
who built it to serve as a summer home
for Portuguese royals in
the late 18th century.
The castle itself is built
around an old monastery,
and is made up of colored sections,
including a red clock
tower and a yellow minaret.
During the revolution
of 1910, the royals fled
and the palace and its
grounds were abandoned.
It wasn't until the 20th century
that it was restored by the state
and earned itself a UNESCO
Heritage Site designation.
King Ferdinand's wide ranging tastes
have made Pena Palace a microcosm
for all the styles of architecture
the world has to offer.